oh my god this is gonna be the weirdest
thing you've had on your show
hi gq this is sam smith here and these
are my 10 essentials
i feel like i talk about robin more than
my own music
i just love this album i got it on vinyl
recently and
i'm obsessed with it it's so cool she's
so cool
she's the reason why i'm queer for me as
as a record from start to finish this
was
so incredible and it's just the
soundtrack to
my summers really it's a perfect summer
album it's
easy to listen to and it is genuinely
like honey the whole record sounds like
honey to me i've got a record player in
my house now and i really enjoy it i'm
impatient sometimes with the whole
changing over and stuff
but it's i find vinyls to be the best
thing to play when you have people
around
there's something so wholesome about
feeling something you know i really
i think we're losing that a little bit
with music when you hold something like
this
you realize it's a piece of art just
like any art it's always a lovely moment
when i hold a final in my hands
my own record this is a magical skin
serum
this is called c e ferrulic
skin cuticle stuff this brand skincare
of course
is my favorite skin care brand i use it
instead of moisturizer
and it's just so good for your skin this
this stuff though
you only use twice a week because it
stains your hands a bit orange it's
incredible
it's just so good for your skin and i've
noticed such a difference with my skin
i used to just always put loads of
moisturizer on my face and i found
this to be so much nicer and there's
another there's a hydrating
uh one as well it sounds like they've
paid me but i have to i have to buy this
they don't give it to me for free
oh it doesn't smell good it just smells
like chemicals
this is leo everyone say hello to leo
sometimes i just like to hold him
i have this in my house as you walk in
my house and everyone
is really offended by it and absolutely
hates it and is scared by it and thinks
it's the grossest thing they've ever
seen but i think it's beautiful
i was with my dad on the trip to bruges
there's a random art shop and i just saw
this in the window and it was really
expensive
i don't know why i got it it made so
much sense in the moment i was like i
have to have that
and now i just i really don't understand
it's a camel
with the baby's head and it's called leo
but i've decided that it's my i think
it's beautiful
and i freak everyone out when they come
around my house and see it
creepy
you're just like what the hell this is a
coffee i love
coffee so much it's an addiction but
it's a good addiction it's one of
i i've actually read many health
benefits of coffee
i love getting a coffee and going for a
walk waking up in the morning
and having a coffee i used to love a
coffee and a cigarette but i've had to
stop smoking because i sing
it's bad for you it kills you so i'm not
really a coffee
um snob i actually love starbucks coffee
starbucks coffee to me tastes a bit like
um ash not ash it's like bit burn
but i kind of like that taste i always
have my coffee just black i don't really
like milk
i find milk a bit weird a lot of the
time i love cheese but i don't like milk
normally i'll have a coffee
and it will last me two hours it will go
completely cold but i will still be
sipping on it
for a couple of hours oh
it smells so lovely this is takeshi
everyone
uh he is a fat cat from japan
he's so cuddly honestly i can't express
like i don't even like cats really i'm
more of a dog person
but look he sits here like this and he
just sits perfectly
he's so sweet i was going through a
breakup
on tour and i was in tokyo and we were
in this
market and um i saw him in the shop
window
and i was feeling so sad that i just
needed to hug
something constantly he became this
funny thing in the tour because i would
treat him
like an actual real life child
the people in the hotel actually
when i walk came back into the hotel
he'd be waiting
by the door for me because my security
would talk to the hotel
and always do it as a joke i just love
him a lot honestly he hugs so well he's
just so
fat i'll always have him on tour with me
he um he has to be everywhere i
am i think he might be the reason why
i'm single too
my biggest joy in life is a tuna melt
from
a place called karma bread which is down
the road for me it's disgustingly
fattening
look at this it's a heart attack and a
sandwich but it gives me so much joy and
whenever i'm on tour
and i'm sad i think about this sandwich
and
it gets me through great for a hangover
great for a broken heart
it looks a bit gross but i just love
beige food basically i like fish and
chips
i love crisps fried chicken
just anything fried really it's
embarrassingly british i think
okay this is the bougie item
oh i spend way too much money on these
this is called sierra troudan
and it's a candle i've been told it's
the oldest candle brand
in the world i love the smell of it if
they all smell
like old churches i don't know why
that's why i like that smell it's a
romantic smell it's heavy
i love it and i mainly love it because i
love the green
the dark green glass and the gold it
reminds my mum loves dark green and it
makes the house look prettier and more
whenever i have visitors in my house
i'll definitely
burn candles and also bath time for me
is a cat i put loads of candles on and
have baths a lot to
de-stress this is my first
shoe my first ever hill
i got this from a drag store called
priscilla
in sydney when i was 22
and it's the first time i ever wore
hills was in this
i stuck this little flower in it looks
pretty gross above my bed there's a
little shelf and i just have it above my
bed
and it always makes happy it's very
dusty and all the sequins are starting
to fall out here
i think what drew me to uh this shoe is
the ruby slippers from wizard of oz i
love judy garden so much
it's my dorothy hill this is a little
picture frame my sister lily who's on
this one here
got me this for valentine's day two
years ago
i was on tour and i was a bit low
because i was missing all my family
and this has got a picture of me my dad
me and my mom
me my sister and then me and my other
sister and i just keep that by my bed
and it comes around with me when i
travel me and my family are very very
close me and my sisters boy best mates
and we've lived with each other on and
off for
the last eight years and yeah then my
rocks sometimes we're too close
sometimes it's exhausting being in the
family to be honest
most of the time it's it's wonderful and
saving the best for last
it might be a bit dirty because i
haven't watched it celine
dion falling into utor it's called
falling into you
around the world that's the world
that's celine i just love this so much
i asked my stylist to get this for me
not very
romantic story but i uh i saw it and i
was like i have to get this t-shirt
because i wanted to wear it for a live
performance
my first memory of music was hearing
it's all coming back to me now
by celine dion and i just love her so
much i went to see her
live in hyde park last year and it's a
beautiful memory to escape to during
these
covered times it's just so incredible to
see someone just stand and just sing and
deliver and
story tell and her humor and her
character is infectious
i look up to her in every way i hope i'm
like celine
when i'm older and it also reminds me a
lot of how to lose a guy in 10 days kate
hudson and
matthew mcconaughey when they go to the
celine dion concert
okay that's it gq you have seen all of
me i have nothing more to show you
i am made up of camel babies and tuna
melts